nous sommes voudrais c'est qu'il ya des
épreuves qui démarre la semaine
prochaine alors qu'est ce qui va se
passer si tous les élèves qui leur
passaient l'épreuve 10 on n'y va pas on
boycotte les épreuves c'est une voix un
contrôle continu
il est là quand il m'a dépassé parce
qu'aujourd'hui il est temps prendre des
décisions il reste là et à 48 heures
pour prendre des décisions
louis quand je dis ça c'est possible
qu'ils étaient là qu'ils aillent pas
mais ils auraient raison de le faire
surtout que fin genre
en fait c'est qu'une seule question
qu'on vous pose c'est est ce que vous
êtes pour ou contre le contrôle continu
et ses services voilà c'est vous vous
nous donnez on comprend mais ménage avec
ce que j'ai excuse moi mais moi je ne
peux pas répondre à cette question car
je vous met ses lancers sont tatoués la
science de la course à devenir
simplifiée comme kesha je suis pour la
descente continue
oui d'ailleurs puisqu'on parle du bac il
ya 75 % des épreuves du bac qui sont en
contrôle continu
mais je pense non mr drevet voilà on
sait pas tout à fait la même
problématique mais peu importe
mais je pense aussi que une épreuve à la
fin anonyme qu'elle a même monté une
épreuve nationale
eh ben l'élève qu'il a il a une certaine
fierté il se dit moi j'ai pas eu un truc
au rabais seulement moi j'ai fait et
vous madame jeu pour la suite pour la
suite puisque l'idée c'est quand même de
vous préparer aux études supérieures et
ben il ya quand même ça mais quand même
tout le monde le veut énorme injustice
l'injustice mine de rien oui c'est très
intéressant ce que vous dites pas ce que
vous dit deux choses déjà premièrement
il faut privilégier la valeur du diplôme
c'est pas sympa pour ce que vous avez
fait passer en contrôle continu et
dernière étape
deuxièmement vous dites oui mais ça va
faire plaisir aux élèves ou quoi mais
genre juste je vous donne l exemple des
étudiants qui sont coincés à l'étranger
et qu'ils peuvent parvenir faire leur
examen
je vous donne l exemple des lycéens qui
ont eu des profs qui ont eu le coup vide
et qui n'ont pas eu d'écho à percer
maquis moque le programme en fait le
problème c'est qu'on est devant nous a
dit ça va très bien se passer la
scolarité ça s'est très mal passé mais
ça c'est mal fait mais personne ni les
difficultés que vous
si l'anglais oneda roumégas celui ci est
ce que vous aimez pas faire des mélanges
mais justement on est en train de
réfléchir pour savoir comment vous allez
vous avec vos profs c'est moins
longtemps que vous attendez les preuves
ne sont pas là pour faire échouer les
élèves
moi je connais pas un seul prof qui soit
là pour faire échouer les élèves alors
on dit que vous réussissiez vous venez
tout les armes donc si jamais il ya des
problèmes pour des élèves qui sont à
l'étranger
on va trouver des problèmes si vous
l'avez vous avez des parties du
programme que vous avez pas étudié et
ben vous pourrez déclarer avec votre
propre que vous n'avez pas étudié cette
partie du louvre actionne départ aux
réformes est décédé par contre mais
l'idée c'est pas de vous coincer l'idée
c'est justement de vous valoriser et de
est de vous faire passer un diplôme mais
dont vous serez fier et que vous ne me
reverrez l'ouverture d'allemagne dans
les études supérieures